franck ist von den möglichkeiten ein
bisschen was den leuten von meiner
persönlichkeit zu zeigen
ich bin noch ganz ehrlich ich muss das
ja selber dann nicht schneiden so haben
wir leute weil meine eigene musik videos
schneide ich ja nur diese sachen musik
hat wahrscheinlich kann einfach so sein
wie ich bin ein bisschen witzig sein
mit netten leuten zusammen sein also zum
beispiel chain hat mich ja damals
angerufen und gesagt hast du bock dabei
zu sein und der ist halt echt ein typ
kennst du ja auch ist halt ein top typ
joyce ist eine super liebe der jools mit
dem habe ich auch viel spaß gehabt
freestyle auf der straße und so weiter
die base ist ein kleiner typ von
willstätt tv ich habe aber letztes noch
gesehen kennst du diese analytics
funktion hat er jetzt so wurde die die
zuschauer quasi sehen kannst du dich an
abonnierter gesehen du hast mich
abonniert am 14 12 2009 herz im takt bei
herz im takt bei hertha ist schon wieder
so lange her waren
wahnsinn dass er schon viel bei youtube
er hatte mir irgendwie fand ich
sensationell
ja das war auch richtig hammer damals
war alles echt super ich habe eine
zeitlang in göttingen ein neues geboren
werden in göttingen gelebt weil meine
mutter das studiert hat und da war
einfach ein ganz anderes leben noch da
war irgendwie studentenstadt und auf der
wiese auf dem reiterhof oder was weiß
ich was es ging hat nie viel geld aber
meine mutter hat immer sehr viel gegeben
und dann sind als rhythmus gekommen und
dann war sie dieses typische freunde
verloren auch so dieses ganze bekannte
soziale umfeld verloren und dann kommst
auf einmal hin und wilster neue freunde
finden wird vielleicht nicht unbedingt
direkt irgendwie aufgenommen haben
willst natürlich mit den coolen sein
hängen wir da irgendwo rum auf der
neusser stadtteil da und dann wurde halt
gekifft dass irgendwelche leute kennen
gelernt und nehme so ergeben sich immer
wieder neue zeiten würdest du sagen du
wärst wenn da nicht die richtige du die
kurve gekriegt hätte es auf die schiefe
bahn geraten oder würdest du sagen ich
noch auf der schiefen bahn also stück
weit war ich auf den plan rufen das
heißt was wir straftat nach kanada reist
kennt die keine ob die keiner kennt doch
natürlich die leute die damals damit zu
tun hatten kennen die solches hätte 10
ja ich glaube schon wo hast du denn die
kurve gekriegt
die kurve gekriegt also wann hast du
gemerkt verdammt hier wasser quasi auf
dem weg zum dealer wie hast du die kurve
gekriegt weil ich hab da hat ja
wahrscheinlich gut davon leben oder
meine davon gut leben können ja aber das
hat dann bei mir eigentlich so den
verlauf genommen dass ich irgendwann
auch aufgehört habe zu kiffen und dann
also es gibt ja auch leute die mit
irgendwas handeln und selber habe nichts
zu tun haben aber für mich war das halt
wirklich so der alltag dass ich
irgendwas geraucht habe an anderen was
mitgebracht habe und ganz ehrlich durch
die musik ich habe zum beispiel letztens
auch gelesen schon vorn hat ist auch
aufgehört zu hilfen wegen seiner stimme
es ist einfach so du brauchst eine
gewisse kondition du brauchst auch eine
gewisse vom kiffen wird er auch der hals
trocken ob der mund wird trocken nur das
gar nicht diese power und wenn du dann
auf einmal auftritte hast von 1 23
stunden länge brauchst du einfach diese
kraft und da war mir die musik dann
wichtiger das kiffen
wenn man jetzt diese cd nimmt was wie
würdest du die stilrichtung beschreiben
ist das so wie du es beschreibst das ist
mal also dass die liste sehr
unterschiedlich oder hast du jetzt
gesagt ich mach ein album aus einem guss
das muss alles 1 1 dieser nedas also das
könnte ich gar nicht da müsste ich dann
wahrscheinlich zehn jahre warten und
hätte dann für jeden stil 20 lieder
das ist man könnte seine narren break
jazz hip hop musik ganz bunter mix ich
würde sagen der rote faden bei dem album
ist es ist alles deutschsprachig es geht
ums leben
da kann man ganz klar sagen so ist es
jetzt nicht unbedingt der absolute panik
song drauf und auch nicht irgendwie der
ich mache ich alle fertig mutter fisher
song sondern es geht halt ins reale
leben und die beats sind halt in einem
weg von meinem produzenten nico tau
gemacht der sich halt auch mit mir
entwickelt labor app du machst auch mit
beim raps ja komisch komisch nicht ich
hab ich hatte nicht mehr mit als ich
erst intakter dann hätte ich es nicht
gesagt und das ist auch noch mutter
rapper wobei das ja auch sehr schnell
ist dieses wodurch die tiere farben
verblasst sie tragen den hass doch
bestimmt er stellt sie in den lagern
stimmt aber es ist aber wo ist die
grenze zwischen rap und gesang also für
mich zum beispiel rap einfach nur
weniger melodisch und schneller und
gesang ist halt melodisch und rap nicht
die moderne form des gedichtes sprich
gesunden ja sein wird seine sportlich
sind sie wenn es sich rein sitz
gesprochen wichtig wenn man hört der
jetzt außerhalb der sich nicht gar nicht
mehr rein beratung erwartet immer darauf
dass irgendwas eltville
was jetzt nicht aber es gibt raps wo ich
dann nichts mehr